- Let's think about the
limit of the square root
of 100 + x - the square root of x,
as x approaches infinity and I encourage
you to pause this video and try to
figure this out on your own.
So I'm assuming you've had a go at it.
So first let's just try to think about it,
before we try to manipulate
this algebraically,
in some way.
So what happens is x
gets really really really really large,
as x approaches,
as x approaches infinity.
While even though this 100
is a reasonably
a reasonably large number,
as x gets really large,
Billion, trillion, trillion trillions.
Even larger than that.
Trillion trillion trillion trillions.
You could imagine that the 100,
under the radical sign,
starts to matter a lot less.
As x approaches really
really large numbers,
the square root of 100 + x is going to be
approximately the same thing as the
square root of x.
So for
really really
large large x's,
we can reason that the square root
of 100 + x is going to be
approximately equal to
the square root of x
and so in that reality,
we are going to
really really really large x's.
In fact,
there's nothing larger,
where you can keep increasing x's,
then these two things are going to be
roughly equal to each other.
So it's reasonable to believe,
that the limit as x approaches
infinity here,
is going to be zero.
You're subtracting this,
from something that is
pretty similar to that,
but let's actually do
some algrebraic manipulation
to feel better about that,
instead of this kind of
hand-wavy argument about
the 100 not mattering as much,
when x gets really really really large
and so let me re-write this expression.
See if we can
manipulate it in interesting ways.
So this is
100 + x - x.
So one thing that might jump out at you
whenever you see one radical,
minus another radical like this.
Well maybe we can multiply
by its conjugate and somehow
get rid of the radicals,
or at least transform the
expression in some way,
that might be a little more useful
when we try to find the limit,
as x approaches infinity.
So let's just and obviously
we can't just multiply it
by anything arbitrary,
in order to not change the value
of this expression,
we can only multiply it by one.
So let's multiply it by a form of one,
but a form of one that helps us,
that is essentially made
up of its conjugate.
So let's multiply this
let's multiply this
times the square root
of 100 + x
+ the square root of x,
over the same thing.
The square root of
100 + x
+ the square root of x.
Now notice this,
of course is exactly equal to one
and the reason why we like
to multiply by conjugates,
is that we can take advantage
of differences of squares.
So this is going to be equal to
and our denominator,
we're just going to have
we're just going to have the
square root of 100.
Let me write it this way actually.
100 + x
+ the square root of x
and our then our numberator,
we have the square root
of 100 + x,
minus the square root of x
times this thing.
Times square root of
100 + x +
the square root of x.
Now right over here,
we're essentially multiplying
A + B times A - B,
will produce a difference of squares.
So this is going to be equal to
this top part right over here,
is going to be equal to
this,
let me do this in a different color.
It's going to be equal to
this thing squared
minus,
this thing,
minus that thing squared.
So what's 100 + x squared?
Well that's just 100 + x,
100 + x
and then what square root
of x squared?
Well that's just going to be x.
So minus x
and we do see that this
is starting to simplify nicely.
All of that,
over the square root
of 100 + x
+ the square root of x
and these x's
x - x will just be nothing
and so we are left with 100 over
the square root of 100 + x +
the square root of x.
So we could re-write the original limit,
as the limit,
the limit as x approaches infinity.
Instead of this,
we just algebraically manipulated it,
to be this.
So the limit as x approaches infinity
of 100 over
the square root of
100 + x
+ the square root of x
and now it becomes much clearer.
We have a fixed numerator.
This numerator just stays at 100,
but our denominator right over here,
is just going to be,
it's just going to keep increasing.
It's going to be unbounded.
So if you're just
increasing this denominator,
while you keep the numerator fixed,
you essentially have a fixed numerator,
with an ever-increasing,
or a super large,
or an infinitely large denominator.
So that is going to approach,
that is going to approach zero,
which is consistent with
our original intuition.